what kind of Airship is that I've never
seen anything like it baby Glade what is
the president doing in our front yard
our entire world is in grave danger I
want you to come with me on an
expedition
I'm not my father the congratulations on
a very deep film I feel like some of
these characters could have been written
for Live Action almost like Oscar bait
like you could be up for best actor for
these performances
[Laughter]
um I know that I'm gonna start things on
a light note inevitably when you do
voice recording I have been told that
there's always a session where it's an
entire day of grunts ooze Oz sound
effects I want to know if that was the
case especially on a film that's an
Adventure film and how does that go you
have a choice you have a choice you can
go in installments right okay all the
end all in one who can do that well I
mean it's like you know you work all day
monthly it's a pay monthly thing so you
can do at the end of every one of the
sessions I chose to go with the finals
15 minute after I said what's the
generic version then what else do you
want I just and then I get the game 15
minutes and everyone I just screamed and
yelled and yeah
and you're like a pay by the year kind
of guy like no no no
he's just paid all down so do those
sessions do they feel bizarre or do they
sort of like are they embarrassing or
are they liberated they're meant to be a
bear
is like now they know how my dog looks
at me
no no
no
wow
um I did a movie preview a couple weeks
ago and I was previewing this film and
the second that the host saw you they
were like oh that's Jake Gyllenhaal they
knew it was you whoa really so and I
think for all of you I felt like in a
sense I was really watching you all
perform well that's unfortunate
particularly in his case but I mean in
my case maybe so much I do have ears
that size so that makes sense but I
don't know
so what do you discover about yourself
when you see yourself being anime
wow
um you see so many micro expressions and
little things where you're like I do
look like that where it's like um it's
more intense than looking in a mirror
because if you look in a mirror you're
like performing for yourself you know
you're trying to like look hot for
yourself
um
and uh they're like let's see your
mirror face
um but yeah they're just like recording
during all the sessions so when you're
doing that embarrassing jumping yelling
screaming they got you it's true yeah
and it's going in there me I never
realized how much I look like Kurt
Russell
[Laughter]
it's uncanny incredible
wow and for you Jake uh I mean I would
just say that they stole my soul and
I'll never forgive them that's literally
the way I act and behave and my facial
expressions are no different from my own
the feeling I mean that's the the face
on the poster is the face I use pretty
much all the time yeah I mean I don't
know I like yeah it was interesting it
was really interesting yeah that's the
face that you just gave her what 22 more
interviews
okay
[Music]
um so I'm gonna go very inside the actor
studio for a second there is a scene in
the film where you or your character
asks your character to explain why he
wanted to be a farmer because you were
an Explorer and he just says I have to
ask why farming he gives such a great
answer it's succinct so I'm gonna ask
all three of you why acting
um
that went over well it's a really really
good questions actually yeah yeah
because because I I could make a
football team
so I wound up in the drama room and you
look like
what does that have to do
like I look like that too and I should
be an actor okay okay I think he's a
very good looking man thank you that's
fine okay
uh why uh I really don't know I really
couldn't tell you I would say that in in
all honesty
um there was a very particular kind of
Joy I got when I performed even from a
very young age and particularly in front
of an audience it was just something
that
um I knew was this like kind of
wonderful exchange of joy and so to me
that's like really infectious but there
are a lot of much more complicated
answers to that question but also just
sheer luck you know all of us get into
it and there's so many people who you
know do it and it's it's literally the
lottery so yeah it is there's a lot of
talents so talented people out there
that yeah I forgot to have luck yeah I
think it's um the joy and then also I
just love playing and like I don't know
having fun I think a lot of this is
um just playing make-believe especially
something like this it's like you're
just uh in your imagination having fun
trying to make people laugh well
speaking of which I think this movie
when I saw it it's such an incredible
found on so many levels and when I saw
it it almost made me wish as much as I
enjoyed it as an adult that I saw it as
a child because I wonder what I would
have thought I'm sure I would have been
obsessed with that world so what do you
think each one of you would have thought
as a child watching this movie we I got
some pretty great Classics as a kid so
yeah it's hard to compare but
yeah well I mean Disney and that's what
Disney does you know they'd make
our our myths their myths is what they
are that's why they stay with us for so
long they point to some kind of truth
that you have no words for you know and
they're classic stories when you break
them down and I think that's their
success
yeah um for you you have a few dad jokes
in this yes is it aligned with your own
sense of humor or how would you describe
your sense of humor compared to I think
that dad jokes is a euphemism for bad
drugs
yeah yeah so um yeah you don't have to
fill a position you just have to know
how to not be funny and that's I can do
that very well so yeah my last question
is for you acting opposite Splat
um how is that for you in the voice
recording both because there's obviously
there's a lot of almost like Bantam but
you're acting opposite like where are
you going in your brain how did you
create Splat in your head um they did a
good job explaining Splat but also Don
did an amazing job impersonating slat or
Splat and
it took me maybe 10 minutes to recover
the first time I heard him make that
noise
um but then after that it was pretty
smooth sailing I I really want I'm
trying to start a campaign for him to do
it on camera again so everyone can see
it but good thing I haven't interviewed
him yet
said about you but
Grandpa's awesome he is not awesome you
gave me a machete for my birthday
classic Jager claimed I was too
so I was told from the other room that I
am to ask you to do your impression of
Splash do it do it
it's not very good it's not very good
but it's fantastic best I can do Splat
come into fruition where did he come
from
uh
yeah
um when is will this be shown in terms
of release let's do
let's do spoiler free yes okay so um you
know Splat came from you know I just
love non-verbal characters you know for
instance like the carpet in Aladdin you
know um and and you know to really just
embrace the joy of animation and that's
what those kind of characters do and our
animators had a blast yeah taking this
eight-legged blob and expressing with
them and and the whole gamut of
animation
your room these characters almost feel
like live action characters because
they're so deeply written the world is
so beautifully created
um and I'm I know from each of you you
drew from personal experience your dad
was a farmer I think you've said before
that when you became a writer you
weren't sure it was going to be a career
and you made your dad proud with Raya
yeah absolutely so what sort of personal
experiences did you draw on because you
got to write what you know
well it was very much that you know
Ethan's story definitely reflects mine
and growing up you know the son of a
farmer and learning to you know to farm
and and then you know having that
realization that yeah it just wasn't it
wasn't for me you know my path was
following this this animation thing and
uh having that conversation with my dad
it certainly wasn't as dramatic as what
we do in the film but that was
definitely uh uh taken from from a very
personal story yeah and all elements
from all three of these characters are
things that we both lived right like we
wouldn't be filmmakers if we didn't have
that ambition that Jaeger has that drive
to continue to chase the Horizon even
though it seems crazy you know and and
but by doing so you sometimes lose time
with your families so so that's
something that we also relate to and
then when Searcher we also know what
it's like to be uh guys that were at one
point going I'm gonna be nothing like my
father but then ending up just like them
later in life but also being now as we
are older as dads ourselves being very
proud that we're like our dads and of
course we're all like Ethan who's at
some point had a rebel against our
parents to become who we were going to
be oh I'm becoming more like my mother
every single day and you realize it you
know as you as you as you go on yeah
okay so again without spoilers there is
a beautiful reveal in this film and I'm
wondering where a storytellers you
decided on that reveal was it in the
very beginning did it involve and sort
of go you had an aha moment or how did
it go well the the reveal in question
was always part of the story but where
it happened
was always in question and it kind of
moved around a little bit and we found
the perfect place for it because uh it's
a it is a very big reveal
um but it also dovetails with Searcher
making a discovery about himself
and they cut those moments kind of
beautifully gelled um but we did move
around a bit we had to search to find
the right place to put it so if when you
were searching sort of for inspiration
not that you need inspiration but
it says what's what are some of the
films that you drew on when you when you
were having these conversations about
writing the film oh yeah well I mean
obviously the the pulp movies the action
adventure movies that we all know like
writers of the Lost Ark and Empire
Strikes Back and great novels like by
Jules vernes and and during the center
of the Earth but also like family movies
like uh you know National Lampoon's
Vacation Loma Sunshine because we needed
a combination of both great adventure
and great you know family comedy to
really give a heart to this thing I'm
wondering if Inner Space
even to the equation at all for obvious
reasons well yeah because it starred our
Dennis Quaid and you know uh watching
all of his filmography but yes we did uh
we did watch Inner Space and write stuff
Don talks about the right stuff almost
daily so he really loves that movie yeah
I think and you know he he played a test
pilot in that but I mean they're
essentially those early astronauts are
Explorers so it felt like Dennis just in
his you know DNA he knew how to play
that role and why were chabuki
um and Jake perfect why why were there
you they your choices well I mean we
were fans of all five of these actors
like uh weight from way back right like
we've been following all their careers
big fans and when you know Jamie uh
Roberts our casting director was like
hey we think about these five I'm like
absolutely we love them but would they
even take a meeting with us and so to
actually be in the room with them uh and
Pitch this movie that was already a
dream come true but to have them
actually join the film and be the
collaborators that they are you know
like when you start out doing these
movies you're telling them about the
characters at the end they're telling us
who the characters are and they've been
just great collaborators ever since so I
know you were a writer at Marvel before
you jumped over to animation so I'm
going to ask you the inevitable Marvel
crossover question if you were to have a
crossover for this film live action
meets animation what Marvel character
would you love to meet up with the clay
I mean I don't mean to kiss the butt of
this guy that's next to me he already
did a Marvel movie called Big Hero 6 and
they and it'd be kind of interesting to
see the clades and the team of Big Hero
6 together love to see Baymax and splat
work together so so I'm going to keep in
the Disney family but also it's still a
Marvel property as well that Don uh you
know directed himself I could get behind
that Big Hero 6 meets strange world yeah
yeah do you see franchise potential for
this because I and do you have stories
written in your minds yet do you oh for
a strange world for this um you know I
we haven't really sat down to do that
because we literally just finished the
film
um and the paint is very wet on this one
so
um you know we love all I can say is we
love this world we love these characters
so much especially seeing the you know
because we didn't you know when you do
one of these movies the you're not with
the actors all together you know it's
all individual and and it's so wonderful
to be to see them all around each other
and and so
um we love these actors we love our
characters so who knows what the future
my last question to both of you
obviously you did Ryan The Last Dragon
together such an incredible movie also
every action driven but a different type
of action so how would you compare how
you sort of describe the action
adventure in this film well this one's a
little bit more like classic Indiana
Jones going into you know exploring new
territory while while Ron The Last
Dragon was very much a martial arts film
they kind of celebrated the martial arts
and dragons in a different culture so so
this one's definitely a ride where like
it's it's not if you think about that
very beginning of Raiders where like
he's trying to run away and a giant
Boulders coming after him uh like that
that's that's kind of the heartbeat to a
lot of the the action sequences in this
film okay you got to show the t-shirts
to go out oh yeah yeah
oh this is amazing where can I get one
oh well I don't know it's all grown
right now our team made these uh and uh
we love them and so we just kind of wear
them uh for these events